so another person who might or might not
have coronavirus
thanks to super spreader donald trump is
his sort of sometimes lawyer rudy
giuliani i genuinely don't know if rudy
giuliani is still donald trump's lawyer
what i do know is rudy did an interview
on fox news last night
and he just couldn't stop coughing
throughout and he's insisting he's still
waiting on a coronavirus test that a few
days ago he had a negative coronavirus
test
you have to see this not only can rudy
not stop coughing he's
sweaty throughout the entire interview
his eyes are half closed but that's
common for rudy in these later afternoon
or early
evening interviews for reasons we've
previously discussed it may or may not
be related to whatever rudy is fighting
off here
listen to this first video this does not
sound good
everybody questions the polls but pretty
consistently
um everybody questions the polls but
pretty consistently
um i i almost feel like i need to to
wear a mask just watching this
here's another one the scientists say
it's okay
he is going to scientists say it's okay
he is going to the scientists say it's
okay
and then here's a third one you can
actually see fox anchor martha mccallum
sort of grimace when rudy giuliani
coughs
i think they both realize that they
accomplish more that way
but the reality is when i hear that
response
that jones is going to listen to the
experts and be
guided and be determined and the
president is going to do it
i mean i was the mayor so again um
people being sick is is not funny uh the
fact that donald trump himself
and everybody around him seems to be at
particular risk because of the behavior
they've chosen to engage in and
ridiculing masks and all of it
it's certainly ironic but it's never
funny when people are sick
it wasn't just the coughing by the way
that was notable
it was also what rudy giuliani said
here's a very horse-sounding giuliani
saying that trump really has learned a
lot from having coronavirus
that you're talking about where it
becomes you know maybe ridiculous like
driving by yourself in a car with one on
but do you think that this this whole
experience for the president will change
the way he looks at it a little bit
sure things like this do change you i
think he indicated that
that he's been educated a lot i think we
have to wait and see exactly
the conclusions that he's drawn from it
but i know he's drawn some conclusions
from what what he's what he's gone
through
and there's a balance here to be struck
between wearing a mask
and wearing a mask to the point of
almost you know a political theater or
or maybe even worse than that fear on
irrational fear
why does trump have to get kovid to
learn about it and change his view it's
sort of like when the end
why does an anti-gay republican only
realize that their policy has hurt
people
when their kid comes out as gay or their
niece
comes out as bisexual or whatever the
case may be why can't they empathize
why aren't they capable of abstract
thought
everything is only i got it oh it's
serious now
here is rudy giuliani on some aimless
rant
about doctors versus scientists and
doctors aren't scientists and it's all
just really really weird what would you
say to joe biden there
well i would say to joe that you don't
really understand what scientists are
first of all listen to your doctors
that's for sure they know your personal
history
doctors really aren't scientists when
they're scientists uh
almost always have competing opinions
that's what science is about
science isn't a didactic dogmatic
religion
there's almost almost every principle of
this kind of science
you know medical science has uh
conflicting opinions
and for example
it isn't science to be wearing that mask
joe
when you're giving a speech and the
people are 30 or 40 feet away from you
the only thing you can affect when you
uh
when you're doing that is a teleprompter
that's closer to you
so i i see through you who is this
interview even targeted at right i mean
when you think of like
who are they try what is the point of
sending rudy giuliani out
at this point particularly coughing like
this why would you go and do an
interview
with such a terrible cough waiting for a
coronavirus test
when the president has coronavirus
maybe i don't understand the psyche of
the trumpist
of the fox news viewer maybe i don't
understand the propaganda value of
sending rudy giuliani out there anyway
coughing is the
are trump is going to see this and say
wow what a
strong giuliani even with the cough even
maybe with coronavirus if that's what it
is he has
he's still going and doing tv interviews
it like
are they that deluded that they would
not think about the fact that
trump is spreading this like wildfire to
people around him
that rudy if indeed he has coronavirus
is contagious and he's at a studio
it seems maybe that's a home studio i
don't know but it seems like a studio
it would that not computer let me know
what you think
cancel you know stay home send somebody
else it's absolutely vile